[Music]
oh boy we have got a mystery box
actually two mystery boxes now i already
know that they're from nintendo because
this one said from nintendo and this
one's a big
mystery question coin block i don't know
who else it could be from
obviously it's nintendo so thank you
nintendo for sending me whatever is in
here
i can't wait to open it up should i
start with small box or big box
i think i'll start with small box been a
while since i've done just sort of a
mystery unboxing
so today is the day oh a
note from isabelle it's an animal
crossing
fall activities november calendar and a
note to say that the product has been
provided by nintendo so product
has been provided by nintendo look at
this these are all of the activities
that i can do oh my gosh the month is
almost over and i have not enjoyed all
of the activities
turkey day this is gonna be awesome the
26th
okay what's in here stickers i love this
game so much
oh my gosh is this
a tom nook hat what
[Music]
i think i'm gonna cry this is something
that i didn't know
that i need it jenna
i have a top look at no
no i also got a little water bottle
this is cute it's an insulated water i
put my coffee in this
look at oh wow look at this what is that
do i take that out
oh oh i'm good what does this mean
all right well i just wanted to show you
my hat it's a very nice hat i
know wow catch me
on the island animal crossing
socks like the socks that i'm wearing
right now
are also from nintendo i'm gonna have
tom nook on my head
and tom nook on my toes mabel
isabelle and tom or timmy or tommy you
can't really i guess
same difference look
at this a little bag
oh my gosh i'm so excited i love this
game so much it honestly
it saved by 2020. nintendo switch
ac adapter you can put your switch right
here
switch in here this is so nice this is
fashion
oh oops sorry
wow what is this happy fall okay
well i'm gonna put this up for my
thanksgiving celebration alone
cause i'm not gonna travel for the
holidays cause colbert happy fall
this is so this is so nice i'm gonna put
it back here
beautiful happy fall
and we've got some leaves this is gonna
be nice for thanksgiving decoration and
some little
lights this is a very very nice little
kit
next up we've got this big mystery coin
box
what could it be
oh oh my gosh what the heck
there is so much stuff in here champion
and nintendo teamed up to launch a
limited edition collection in honor of
the super mario brothers
35th anniversary
look at these pins these pins
are perfect we even have a pez dispenser
another
thermos i have a thermos with my coffee
every morning so now i'm going to get to
really switch it up we've got
mario and animal crossing
together what a great day oh
a little coin box of what is this is
there something i can eat
coin candies yes it is i'll have that
what an incredible box
can you believe i have a domino cat on
right now let's take a look at this
this is nice this is like a very
premium sweatshirt
do you see what's on my head right now
tom nook do you see this sweatshirt
this is a very nice material oh my gosh
and sweatpants to boot
flower power this is so nice i'm wearing
this tonight
do you see our decoration back here
happy fall oh these fit nice they're
gonna be real nice when i'm not wearing
two pairs of pants
[Music]
this is this is incredible this is an
amazing fit i haven't had a piece of
champion
gear since i was like in high school
because tyler's like a photographer he
could like take some cool like
i don't ever want to take it off i don't
have to whoa look at my leg look at my
leg hold on
can you believe i'm already wearing
nintendo socks
no those were on my feet look at this
bag
now i'm playing show and tell just let's
get my nintendo switch in there
this was probably one of my most
favorite
mystery gift boxes i just can't believe
how nice this is like the
i think i'm into champion i didn't even
know it
well i haven't i did two and i didn't
know that like i didn't know
now i know they go lego mario's here
i don't know what else to say what do
you guys think do you think this is
awesome because even if you say no i'm
no you're gonna i'm gonna call you a
liar because this is incredible
wow wow world one one set
does that mean
well thanks for watching i'm gonna go do
a photo shoot now
[Music]
you